start with the industry that keeps
Nevada going gaming all resorts and
casinos are closed right now by the
coronavirus and right now the Gaming
Control Board is discussing how to open
them once again board members are
hearing from health officials this
morning and this afternoon on the status
of the coronavirus cases and testing
numbers showed that the cases have
actually gone down in the last month or
so
Gaming controls also hearing
recommendations on how resorts can deal
with keeping guests safe that is vital
for opening to visitors
UMC CEO Mason van howling highlighted
temperature checks and screenings that
should be done and he also revealed a
new plan for tourists who do test
positive so we have approaching ten
properties out there that have agreed to
accept positive guests for lodging
services if the patient or a guest or a
visitor is identified with kovat
positive patients so we haven't provided
those names we'll provide those two
resorts but just so you know we've
worked out that logistical coordination
again that is the voice of that man
Mason Ben howling from UMC the CEO over
there UMC is now discussing the legality
of requiring a test for visitors the
Southern Southern Nevada Health District
is recommending all casino workers get
tested and then retested every two weeks
we'll have a lot more on this important
meeting at 3 o'clock and five o'clock
several casinos around town have already
released targeted opening dates Treasure
Island for example hope to reopen today
that's not happening Caesars Palace
looked at Friday the Wynn in the encore
June 1st but now all those casinos have
dates before June 4th blocked off we
have more details on this at 8 News
now.com